we have other news this morning
including the final u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan it is now just hours away
now this could be the most dangerous
phase yet rockets were fired toward the
kabul airport overnight after a u.s
drone strike hit a vehicle loaded with
explosives two suspected isis members
were killed there the attempted attacks
are not stopping flights from leaving
the airport though charlie daggett is
tracking the final push to get americans
out f
out of afghanistan charlie good morning
to you it's getting very dicey there
very dicey indeed gail yes u.s defense
officials tell cbs news that that rocket
attack happened just after dawn a u.s
missile defense system were able to was
able to shot shoot down some of them or
they never made it to the airport either
way nobody was injured and the
evacuation continued uninterrupted
a burnt out shell is all that's left of
the vehicle it's said to have served as
the launch pad for this morning's rocket
attacks at least five rockets sprayed in
the direction of the airport anyway some
landing in nearby neighborhoods others
shot down by the missile defense system
the attempted attack comes a day after
the pentagon confirmed it conducted a
second u.s drone strike to target isis k
a u.s defense official tells cbs news
the strike was ordered after two men
were seen loading explosives into the
trunk of a car it's unclear whether they
were rigging a car bomb or loading up
explosive vests but it was deemed to be
an imminent threat to the airport
taliban officials and afghan media said
instead the blast killed nine civilians
including a number of small children the
pentagon has acknowledged there could be
civilian casualties as one of the
largest airlifts in u.s history now
enters its final hours american forces
are focusing on getting themselves out
of afghanistan safely after helping more
than a hundred twenty thousand civilians
escape those who didn't make it to the
airport have been making a break for the
border of neighboring countries like
pakistan by the hundreds of thousands
the u.s state department said there may
be some u.s citizens who don't make the
deadline along with thousands of afghans
granted u.s visas who are left behind
but national security adviser jake
sullivan told ed o'keefe on face the
nation the taliban won't stand in their
way the taliban have both communicated
to us privately and publicly that they
will allow for safe passage we're not
just going to take their word for it
he said there would be significant
consequences that the taliban do not
follow through not just diplomatic and
economic but other tools would be
brought to bear tony
charlie dagetta for us in doha charlie
thank you i